des dizaines de migrants africains air
sur les plages d'aden la grande ville
portuaire du sud yémen
vêtus d'habits de fortune ils attendent
d'être prises en charge par l'hôpital
local
tous ont risqué leur vie pour traverser
la mer rouge depuis les pays de la corne
de l'afrique comme l'ethiopie l'erythrée
ou la somalie l'an dernier près de 138
milles migron réaliser ce périlleux
voyage
le phénomène de l'immigration illégale
ainsi que l'augmentation du nombre de
passeurs ont entraîné une pression très
importante sur la population de la
région en particulier et celle du yémen
en général les chiffres n'ont cessé
d'augmenter
souvent 400 à 500 africains arriver
chaque jour les migrations illégales a
commencé en secret en 2010 et à
augmenter lorsque la guerre a éclaté en
raison de l'insécurité de la faiblesse
des autorités sécuritaires du manque de
garde-côtes sur les rivages yéménite
ce qui a contribué à l'augmentation du
nombre d'africains que les passeurs
amène sur les côtes yéménites pour ces
migrants la vie au yémen n'apportant
rien d'hospitaliers la plupart d'entre
eux ignorent que le pays ravagé par la
guerre civile et doit lutter également
contre l'épidémie de coronavirus selon
l'onu le pays compte près de 24 millions
de personnes ayant besoin d aide
humanitaire pour faire face à la
situation désespérée du yémen les
nations unies ont obtenu 1,35 milliard
de dollars de promesses de dons